أضاءت ليلة القطب الشمالي عندما
انفصلت الأرض عن الشق وانفجر قلبها المنصهر
وأدت أسابيع من الزلازل إلى عرض نار
كوكبنا وقوته
بعد ثوران بركاني، حيث توجد
دائمًا مستويات عالية من الغازات السامة، وهو
مصدر القلق الرئيسي في أيسلندا الآن هو
توزيع الغازات السامة.  مع الرياح،
لا يمكن أبدًا تحديد متى
أو ما إذا كان بركان مثل هذا بالقرب من
بلدة جريندفيك سيثور على وجه التحديد، ولم يخاطر المسؤولون
على الرغم من إجلاء
السكان بعد أسابيع من الهزات الأرضية،
وشعروا بآلاف الهزات في
نوفمبر، وكان الجميع يعرفون ما الذي يفعلونه
لحسن الحظ، لم يكن من الممكن جلب أي شيء من
مدينة فيك عندما اندلع البركان الذي يقع على بعد حوالي 2 ميل
أخيرًا
هذا الشق في سطح
عالمنا بالقرب من 4 كم أو أكثر من 2 متر، مما أدى إلى
قذف الحمم البركانية السابقة في
أيسلندا استمرت أسابيع أو حتى أشهر
لسوء الحظ  بالنسبة لسكان
groix، من المستحيل تحديد المدة التي
سيستمر فيها هذا
في بلدة Grindvik،
الأضرار الناجمة عن الزلزال واضحة، وقد
تتبعها الحمم البركانية إذا استمر هذا النشاط،
فالسؤال الكبير هو هل ستكون gr uh صالحة
للسكن على المدى الطويل  يعتمد تحديد
ما إذا كان بإمكان الناس العودة إلى هنا على الإطلاق
على مجموعة جديدة من
الظروف الجيولوجية التي يتم إنشاؤها الآن
لـ plin CNN بالقرب من Grindvik
أيسلندا